Did you know 2015 is the 100th year anniversary of the battle of Gallipoli?
Today, we're remembering some of the finest soldiers in history.
The battle of Gallipoli took an enormous toll on both sides.
Over half a million brave souls were lost in just nine months.
Every year, tens of thousands of Australians, New Zealanders,...
...as well as millions of Turks visit Gallipoli to pay respects to their brave ancestors.
Out of this catastrophe, an unexpected outcome emerged.
The battle of Gallipoli paved the way for peace forever.
Mustafa Kemal Ataturk, the legendary commander and founder of modern Turkey, said it best:...
"You, the mothers, who have sent your sons from faraway countries,..."
"...wipe away your tears."
"Your sons are now lying in our bosom and are at peace."
After having lost their lives in this land, they have become our sons as well.
Discover all this and more in Turkey: Home of Gallipoli.